tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video io sono fan i j
oggi siamo finalmente sull'ultima
puntata di ju on the crush ci abbiamo
messo un senso messo un secolo perché ho
cercato di rimandare questo evento il
più lontano possibile
capirete presto il perché comunque direi
di ricapitolare proprio velocemente i
vecchi capitoli allora abbiamo iniziato
con la fabbrica desolata dove c'era fufi
che poi è morto fu un fiume morto vabbè
lasciamo perdere poi l'ospedale
abbandonato gli appartamenti disabitati
e il penultimo episodio è stato la
sventura in un sorvegliante e oggi siamo
qui su questo episodio speciale che
normalmente non è sbloccabile perché in
teoria il gioco dovrebbe finire con la
sventura di un sorvegliante ma se si
raccolgono tutti gli oggetti nascosti
che si trovano negli altri ribelli
ovvero questi che state vedendo
frammenti di foto di giornali eccetera
si può sbloccare l'ultimo episodio che è
il più pauroso di tutti credo dal nome
credo che sia così che è la casa
maledetta prima di iniziare la ga
soltanto una curiosità volevo dirvi la
casa maledetta è l'unico luogo del gioco
che rispecchia il film avendo visto il
film raga posso per annunciarvi che
stavolta veramente più paura delle altre
volte allora siamo partiti c'è un
cancello in legno permesso io sono era
il campanello se fossi in te però è una
scelta tua fa come vuoi ok ma che bel
giardino l'illuminazione fantastica
metti due cazzo di lampioni però ok
perfetto c'è una porta ok la vedo
stiamo per stiamo per entrare nella casa
maledetta e qui mi sorge il primo dubbio
ma perché cazzo stai andando lì dentro
non lo sapremo mai
comunque bene cerca un pannello io
suonerei se fossi in te perché non è
molto no niente niente lui entra
tranquillamente nelle case degli altri
uno si sveglia così di sera dice vado
nella casa abbandonata così a caso
perfetto c'è della roba a terra non
voglio sapere cos'è sebbene c'è il piano
di sopra si raga è identica a quella del
film uguale ok la porta si è già
sbarrata dei capelli
fantastico questo la dice lunga su
quanto sei intelligente to brutto ignota
di merda qual è il tuo nome che ti
voglio sfottere i video e 6 e vi sarebbe
fufi chi è quella donna orribile mamma
papà che nessuno risponde che diavolo
succede
erika perfetto abbiamo scoperto il nome
dell'ultimo demente che andremo a
controllare che erika allora erika io e
te dobbiamo fare un bel discorso adesso
ci sentiamo tranquilli e mi spieghi
perché cazzo sei entrata qui dentro
vabbè raga direi di andare avanti allora
come al solito i suoni cestini sono un
optional e buttano tutto a terra così
come viene
cos'è quella roba c'è una scatola una
porta sbarrata dai capelli perfetto
mica un regalo per me no perfetto
torniamo indietro ci sono un casino di
porter haga voglio soltanto dirvi che vi
giuro dato che ho visto il film vi giuro
che è uguale identica al film la casa è
stata riprodotta sembra quasi nei minimi
dettagli come nel film quindi veramente
la cosa inquietante e io personalmente
so qual è il posto in cui non devo
andare qual è il vostro peggior e
diciamo permesso non c'è nessuno vero
ok vi dico soltanto che nel film ogni
[ __ ] stanza ogni [ __ ] stanza di
questa casa è successo un qualcosa di
orribile tipo la vasca da bagno è un
brutto ricordo
si è fermato merda no non guardare lì
dentro non guardare dentro noi ha dentro
non potrei nel tronco trento ok via via
via via via
perfetti una mano mi sta tentando di
afferrare il naso ok siamo vivi raga
c'era una mano tranquilli
ok c'è qualcosa qui a terra che non
avevo visto cos'è una batteria perfetto
mi sembra ovvio sente un telefono
suonare tu continua tranquillamente il
bagno vado a rispondere io al telefono
non ti scomodare
voglio mi sembra un po strano però il
fatto che è tutto girato all'interno
della casa perché comunque si la casa è
uguale a quella del film ma non mi
ricordavo diciamo che fosse così grande
e quindi sinceramente non so quanto
modulare questo episodio perché la casa
non mi ricordo che fosse proprio così
enorme prova beh noi proviamo lo stesso
rega sto sentendo di continuo squillare
un telefono però quasi sotto abbiamo già
controllato tutto sta portando si apre
non ci rimane che andare al piano di
sopra cosa pessima però dobbiamo farlo
perché l'unico appunto che ci manca per
andare avanti ok perché lurida demente
se entrata qui dentro perché se entrata
qui dentro perplesse entrata qui dentro
c'è un quadro c'è un quadro fantastico
è bello molto bello passare le ore
osservarlo però devo andare avanti ok
ragazze è il corridoio sono terrorizzato
dal corridoio sono terrorizzato dal
corridoio non c'è nessuno ok non c'è
nessuno come non detto perfetto
fatemi entrare qui dentro prima che
scleri allora non mi ricordo
sinceramente che cosa c'è all'interno di
questa stanza perché non me la ricordo
bene la casa memoria non c'è la piantina
stampata nel cervello diciamo però so
soltanto che c'è un posto dove non devo
andare
e quando lo troverò ve lo dirò loro c'è
un materasso bellissimo sono le 28 di
notte perché cazzo sei una casa
abbandonata dalle 2 e 8 di notte perché
non lo saprò mai
va beh noi tentiamo di fare qualcosa qui
dentro che non so che cosa devo fare
c'è un appendiabiti che sinceramente non
so che cosa mi può servire poi c'è un
armadio
c'è un armadio raga c'è un armadio c'è
un armadio io so già che cosa ci troverà
dentro l'armadio non aprire l'armadio
perché l'ho aperto perché l'ho aperto
marmaglia un gatto [ __ ] era solo
un gatto ok perfetto
pensavo di trovarci la ragazza proprio
del genere però va bene c'è anche il
bambino
buonasera non volevo disturbare l'ultima
volta che ho visto un bambino in un
armadio stavo guardando le cronache di
narnia
diciamo che non è proprio la stessa cosa
però vabbè c'è una chiave lì se la
prendi e sparito il bambino non me ne
fotte niente prendi quella [ __ ]
chiave elevati dal cazzo dai minchia
quanto ci vuole è perfetta ce l'ho fatta
prendere una [ __ ] chiara e chiudi la
porta magari con un magari chiusi da un
po più lentamente già che ci siamo no
brava ce l'abbiamo fatta chiave della
stanza perfetto raga allora adesso non
so dove andare
direi di dare un'occhiata prima il
corridoio e poi prova ad aprire la porta
che stava pian terreno che penso che la
chiave salva questo c'è un gatto c'è il
gatto di prima ti puoi avere dalle palle
che devo andare piano di sotto
oddio oddio se una colonia di gatti per
fatto io ma iniziano schivato un gatto
alla matrix oddio ci attaccano
ok merda merda merda merda è perfetto mi
stanno guardando malissimo dio si
attaccano tutti insieme devono diventare
snodabile per schivarli tutti ok
perfetto c'è un flash assurdo sono
spariti gatti non mi faccio domande mi
levo subito dalle palle perché io qui
dentro non ci voglio stare io levo le
tende subito perché qui dentro meno ci
sono e meglio è
permesso devo andare al piano di sotto
c'e nessuno bene ok è già un vantaggio
allora diamo al piano di sotto
no veramente vogliono controllare prima
il corridoio perché non ho visto che
cosa c'è allora c'è un armadio
scorrevole poi pieno di armadi raga
ebbene vediamo se si apre spero di no
spero vivamente che non si apra ma
invece si apre purtroppo ok piano molto
piano molto piano detto molto ma non è
un armadio e una stanza è una stanza ok
era una porta scorrevole basta c'è un
libro ok
c'era un flash bellissimi era soltanto
un flash quindi c'è un quaderno vediamo
di prenderlo e levarsi dalle palle anche
di qua è bene non so che cosa mi possa
si apre da solo ma che cazzo è sta roba
che consiglio c'è un occhio
c'è un occhio nel quaderno ok
non voglio far domande la privacy non
c'è neanche più nei diari segreti ormai
ti spiano ovunque
non so che cosa ci sono entrato a fare
qui dentro ma me ne vado
ok ok salve buongiorno mi fa passare che
devo andare nell'altra stanza perché c'è
un taglierino in mano
ok grazie grazie mille non so non ho
idea di chi fosse ma non mi economia
simpatico quindi va bene così
usciamo di guà immediatamente sì perché
non le aprì normalmente le porte devi
fare il demente ogni volta c'è un
cestello e c'è una lavatrice cos'è sta
roba è una lavatrice sì non c'è niente
per ora gas soltanto due batterie che
finora sono andato avanti con due
batterie basta a sto punto raga direi di
controllare la porta in fondo al
corridoio che chiusa perfetto
meno male aggiungerei in meno male e poi
cesta portati che non ha idea di che
cosa sia ok si è aperta la sola non ho
neanche toccata
c'è un cesso perfetto entra pure no che
fa
oddio e se io dovessi andare al cesso
come faccio io avrei dei bisogni
niente va bene e non andiamo a sto punto
ok ragazzi di scendere perché il sesso
si la porta d'accesso si chiude da sola
e andiamo al piano di sotto ad aprire la
porta che era rimasta chiusa
dato che abbiamo la chiave è se tutto va
bene qui dentro dovrei trovarci da
chiave per entrare nella porta al piano
di sopra quella chiusa che dovrebbe
essere l'ultima se mi ricordo bene nel
film perché lì dentro diciamo che non ci
vorrei entrare però sarò costretto a
farlo lo so già
ok se si apre st maledettissima porta mi
fa un favore perfetto si sta aprendo
naga allora questa se mi ricordo bene la
cucina e la cucina
permesso ok vedo che è tutto bello
ordinato quindi già presenta benissimo
si è la cucina è anche il salotto tutte
e due insieme ok
bene come al solito i cestini non li
usiamo non fa niente c'è il televisore
si è acceso ok perfetto cambia canale
cambia canale cambia canale cambia
canale non funziona bene questa ok c'è
un occhiobello
buongiorno e sto cercando una chiave sia
tranquillo bene c'era un occhio che va
beh noi non facciamoci domande come al
solito andiamo avanti non le ordinate io
le pizze ma se vuole il pacchetto può
darlo nè ok perfetto è sparito non
facciamo domande c'è il telefono
devo rispondere maledizione perché è di
un'ora che sta squillando ok perfetto
c'è non c'è la cornetta però si la pizza
si è arrivato prima il fattorino l'ho
presa io la pizza l'ho appoggiata sul
tavolino è perfetto ok c'è una c'è una
foto bellissima tutti quei volti
oscurati anche fufi c'è anche fufi per
chi non avesse visto il film i volti
oscurati sono di chi muore quindi quelli
sono i personaggi che ho controllato
prima
presumo che presto se ne aggiungerà un
altro di personaggio morto che è quello
che so appunto come andando adesso va
beh noi direi di ieri
ok ok ok calmi calmissimi questo non me
l'aspettavo
vabbè facciamo finta di niente
proseguiamo c'è la porta che che porta
alla cucina scusate il gioco di parole
se tutto va bene qui dentro dovrei
riuscire a trovare la chiave per il
piano di sopra
ok non promette bene faccio che salvare
già da adesso perché si sta guardando
intorno ok
ciao la pizza l'ho lasciata sul tavolino
è arrivato prima il fattorino perché sei
triste che è successo il presunto 8 a
scuola poi parlarmene sono qui per
questo posso aiutarti si perfetto non
farmi si occhialino mi fai pena
tranquillo poi parlarmi di quello che
vuoi
sì però non deve urlare maledetto
stronzo
ho detto che poi parlarmi di quello che
vuoi ma è scappato raga non so dove è
andato ma sinceramente non me ne frega
niente torniamo nella porta di prima
ok ragazzi siano ci siamo piano piano
piano permesso non or cattive intenzioni
sto soltanto cercando una chiave per il
piano di sopra quindi non forte scherzi
bene c'è che succede siamo entrati raga
non so che cosa oddio c'è una porta
vetrata si cela la vedo ragala vedo c'è
la chiave
vedo la cucina però qua c'è uno
sportello che non se riesco ad aprirlo
non si apre perfetto c'è qualcosa qui
dentro di rilevante che ne so un bambino
capelli uomini morti fattorini che
portano le pizze qualsiasi cosa di
rilevante ficacci un calcio a sto punto
non so che non c'è la maniglia a
prefetto l'ho trovata
l'ho trovata bene ma che cazzo ma che
stai facendo cioè ok perfetto se vuoi la
pizza e nel salotto
ok ok ok mista addio mista stuprando
merda librati sei più sexy del solito
fattelo dire non mi mangiare ok ci sono
perfetto per è sparita è sparita è
sparita perfetto se calmissimi merda non
me lo aspettavo neanche questa l'era
prima apparizione nella casa della della
ragazza perfetto ripreso il controllo di
me stesso
è fantastico vediamo di entrare in
questa [ __ ] porta voglio andarmene di
qui prima possibile
ok napolista [ __ ] porta di raci un
calcio ma fa qualcosa
ok se nessuno vero perfetto c'è un
cestino raga io veramente non ne posso
più
la cucina diversamente dalle altre
stanze sembra più ordinata c'è la porta
come al solito la pubblicità di garnier
e anche dentro la casa
c'è la cucina quindi dov'è la nutella
come al solito anche nell'ultimo
episodio di the grudge andiamo a cercare
la nutella cercano soltanto la nutella
non mi far del male non mi far del male
non mi guardare così ok perfetto già che
ce li potevi dirmi dove la nutella e non
è che non potevi dirmelo prova beh c'è
un forno a microonde e vabbè
accontentiamoci della fottutissima
chiave se riesco a prenderla
ok ci siamo chiave della stanza ok raga
ma rimane soltanto una porta se non mi
ricordo male non ce ne sono più di porte
quindi l'ultima porta ad aprire è quella
rimasta al piano di sopra anche perché
le altre sono coperte dai capelli quindi
non non ci trovo al senso non riesco ad
aprire il frigo maledizione la troverò
prima o poi sta [ __ ] nutella ve lo
prometto raga ve lo prometto
bene speriamo di non incontrare nessuno
nel tragitto
ovviamente come posso ve l'avevo detto
che non era come l'ospedale quindi non
era enorme
in compenso infatti c'erano soltanto due
batterie ok hai visto qualcosa perché no
perfetto ok andiamo al piano di sopra
ragazze
dicevo come come vi avevo detto non è
enorme come posso ovviamente essendo una
casa il cazzo fai che cazzo fai
ok c'è il bambino è diventato pelato ti
sono caduti i capelli ti sono caduti i
capelli è veramente con tutti gli
infarti che mi hai fatto prendere
veramente dovrebbero essere caduti a me
i capelli se devo essere sincero un
consiglio ce l'avrei vai a chiedere a
tua sorella che ne ha fin troppi di
capelli e ragga vi sbagliavate quando
dicevate che la tipa dei capelli lunghi
e dalla madre non è la madre e la
sorella credetemi
vai a chiedere a lei comunque perché ne
ha fin troppi è rimasta ad aprire raga
l'ultima porta c'è qualcosa qui no
perfetto
l'ultima porta mi si sta esaurendo
nell'ultima batteria quindi muoviamoci
è la porta raga che vi dicevo all'inizio
che non volevo aprire era proprio questa
perché all'interno c'è una cosa che
preferirei non aprire però devo farlo
per forza permesso ok non c'è nessuno
bene ma porca [ __ ] si flash di merda
perfetto la regala stanza è vuota
rimane soltanto da fare la cosa che
prevedevo dall'inizio che è questa
l'armadio il [ __ ] armadio di the
grudge è l'ultima cosa in cui voglio
entrare perché è veramente credo che io
ci deve entrare
ok ragazzi si sta esaurendo la batteria
datti una mossa porca [ __ ] datti una
mossa
non riesco non riesco ad aprirla forte
dell'arma ok perfetto ci siamo
bene ci devi entrare ok è caduto il
cappello del fattorino è caduto il
cappello del fattorino
ok che ami a chi cazzo stai chiamando la
pizza lai ordinata prima il fattorino
non c'è più come potuto vedere sentire i
rumori di sopra perfetto raga perfetto
ok ve lo svelo raga l'armadio e
l'entrata per la soffitta nella soffitta
c'è qualcosa che veramente non vorrei
scoprire perfetto non c'è nessuna già un
buon segno perché devi andare in
soffitta perché devi andare in soffitta
non ti girare non ti girare fa misto
favore non ti girare non ti girare ok
non c'è nessuno ma non ci fosse ci sono
dei sacchetti
ok non c'è c'è un telefono c'è un
[ __ ] telefono ok ok da merda merda
merda merda aiuto perché non c'è gli
occhi ok come non detto
perfetto va indietro o indietro ma
indietro
quanto sei brutta ok ma guarda che è
stronzo adesso che mi ha buttato giù
cazzo è ok
salve via via corri corri maledetto
stronzo cordi aprì la porta vai via
non ci posso credere sono ancora vivo e
mi è rimasta mezza batteria non è che
sia così contento di essere vivo in
teoria preferire finisce qua ma
evidentemente ancora non è finito cosa
devo fare ancora
raga e la guerra comunque era quello il
punto che stavo dicendo sin dall'inizio
era era l'armadio che dal punto dove non
volevo entrare era proprio armadio
perché mi ricordavo della soffitta in
realtà ragazzi in soffitta sono nascosti
veri corpi del bambino gatto e della
ragazza che i capelli lunghi
il problema era che adesso mi è rimasto
un cazzo di batteria e non so dove
andare
la porta aperta perfetto ok ok usciamo
di qua esci brutto stronzo esce
maledizione non riesca non riesco più a
camminare ragazzo no sono sfinito deve
uscire di qua maledizione non ci sono
più i capelli
esci da questa maledetta porta maledetta
stronza perché sei entrata ok esci di
qua
esci da stamane ricca porta s
oddio ok ok ok mi avvio via via via via
via rientra nella porta rientro nella
porta dietro nella porta o cazzo
ce la fai a chiudere no
genio bacco dio ci siamo siamo ancora
vivi
mio dio non ci posso credere
ebbene vi giuro che contino che succede
succedendo
che cazzo sta succedendo
no no no dio mio no ma va indietro cosa
la guardia fare brutto idiota mio zio
l'acquatica pellicciai
è occupato fratello
per favore che sta messo veramente male
ma perché siamo perché ci stiamo
guardando perché ci stiamo guardando
perché perché non te ne vai via dal
canto perché perché la stai guardando
pronte yacht a cazzo ma vai via ma cosa
ok non farvi del male non farmi del male
ti prego farò qualsiasi cosa ti prego
farò io i capelli a tuo fratello diventa
rosso parrucchiere di tagliare i capelli
ti pulire la faccia la mattina perché tu
non te la polizi ma fa quello che vuoi
ma non mi prendere ti prego nomi
prendere ok è sparita è sparita
che cazzo è successo oddio oddio no no
no no no no mi sta mio zio mi sta
trascinando merda che cazzo sta
succedendo perché sono di nuovo qui ma
ok
raga non so che cosa sta succedendo
sono stato trascinato di sopra nella
nella soffitta
adesso c'è una specie di cinematica non
voglio andare a controllare in soffitta
neanche con la cinematica merda
ok ok siamo che è successo sono io sono
le mie unghie quelle bene mi ha
trascinato dove mi ha trascinato di
nuovo nella porta di prima penso in
soffitta ok ragazzi siamo entrati nella
porta di prima stiamo tornando
nell'armadio stiamo tornando
nell'armadio stiamo tornando di sopra
cazzo ok devo tornare di sopra perché
anche con la cinematica non posso andar
fuori no ci sono i sacchetti ok mi ha
messo dietro i sacchetti o cosa non
spostare i sacchetti non sposta non
spostare i sacchetti non spostare i
sacchetti non spostare ok è uscita una
mano a caso che penso sia la mano di
erika
ti sta bene brutta [ __ ] per quello che
mi hai fatto passare così impari ad
entrare nelle case abbandonate alle 2 di
notte è ok
oddio abbiamo finito
non ci posso credere posso tirare un
sospiro di sollievo ora che abbiamo
finito giù con the crush come mi
aspettavo raga un finale allegro e se
devo essere sincero nel profondo del
cuore sono contentissimo che siano
scattati tutti idioti di merda
così imparano ad entrare in posti in cui
non devono entrare
va bè ragazzi siamo finalmente giunti al
termine yulan the grudge e finisce qui
vi annuncio raga chiesto per iniziare
adesso che finisce the grudge sto per
iniziare un altro gioco sempre per la
wii sto per iniziarla punto è sempre un
horror è a mio parere non so
sinceramente se fa paura come the grudge
ma fa veramente paura anche questo basti
pensare che all'inizio ero indeciso se
fare the grudge o questo qui quindi
prima ho fatto dei greggi adesso faccio
questo qui nuovo e arriverà tra poco
quindi tranquilli è veramente vi voglio
ringraziare perché la serie di the
grudge ha avuto un
successo incredibile quindi raga vi
ringrazio veramente per averla seguita
vabbè raga come al solito servi dove
piaciuto lasciate un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook come in ogni
video trovate nella descrizione se non
siete ancora iscritti iscrivetevi e noi
ci vediamo al prossimo video bella
ragazzi